let's get cracking so good morning
everyone uh we
are one lesson into further integration
at the moment
excuse me at the moment it's going to i
hope still feel
pretty similar to what you've been doing
in extensive one
just to clean my back when we were
having a look at that uh increasingly
large concentric circles diagram right
one of the things that we learned in
extension one was how to integrate
something
by substitution which is just a fancy
way of reversing the chain rule
right we always provide a substitution
in extension wipe integration and we'll
often provide a substitution
in extension to integration but the
skill we're going to focus on today
and we're going to sort of drill down a
little further in tuesday's listening
will be
when you don't get geared as
substitution how do you determine it
remember that um metaphor i gave you for
opening the mystery box you have to
think for a remit and
concept like well which ways will i be
minus you have to make some choices
right it's not just
automatic now we're going to start off
dipping our toes in
sometimes even though it's not automatic
it's
pretty close have a look at this right
they'll say
using a suitable substitution integrate
such right now when you have a look at
it because of the way that it's crafted
[Music]
it's not too arduous to think what might
be a useful thing that i could introduce
and say
let you equal this and we'll make
everything dramatically
easier would anyone like to make a
suggestion
let u let's just order this down on the
side by the way
let u equal what's underneath the
radical sign
in the denominator so if i go x cubed
plus
one this is a good choice right it's
good because you can see
what's problematic about this is this
square root business right
it's almost like if that square root
wasn't there just
visualize it for a second if the square
root wasn't there you can tell me
almost immediately you don't even need
to do the formal way what would this
integrate into without the square root
zone
i think what family functions
you've got an x squared on top you run x
cubed plus one on the bottom
this is going to get a lot isn't it
because your numerator
is almost almost exactly it's only off
by a constant coefficient
compared to your denominator but that
square root is what makes it problematic
so in order to sort of get away from
that problem this is this substitution
here
will allow us to treat this more or less
as like a regular polynomial which is
about
what's going to happen if we're going to
make a substitution for u we need to
make a substitution for
dx as well because we want to change the
variable integration
so as you're used to in extension one
let's go ahead
and differentiate the thing we're going
to substitute in
this is not too difficult we're going to
get 3x squared 3x squared thank you very
much
now at this point here you've got a few
choices of how to do your notation
um they're not going to be substantially
different in terms of the way you
approach
the question i'm going to advocate for
one particular way but i'll just go
signal
right out the gate of all the ways you
can do
excuse me and i can think of at least
three properly different ways that
you'll all have seen in all your classes
right
none of them is perfect they're all
slightly a bit of a compromise
so here's one way that we can set this
up
i've got a d u on dx here i've got a 3x
squared here
and i can see several of these
components of what are going to appear
in here to do my substitution
right one of the waves that's going to
make this easy for me to minimize the
amount of work and confusion
is to try and get the dx and the x
squared which i see
in my integral to appear together and
then i can just do a straight
substitution here right
so in this case that means two things
i'm going to multiply both sides by this
dx thing here which gives me this over
here
and just going to give me d u over here
and then at the same time i don't really
want 3x squared i actually just want
a single x squared so simultaneously
i'll divide both sides
by three you okay with that now i said
right out the gate right
it's not a perfect way to do things
because in reality
this this thing here this is not a
fraction right do you
on dx we write it as a fraction because
that's kind of how chain rule
works but really if you think back to
the beginning of calculus right
there's all kind of weird limiting
processes and like dividing by zero
business
there's a lot of stuff under the hood
that's going on here okay
so by right we shouldn't actually be
able to do this we're treating d
on the x like a fraction even though it
isn't really
so that's kind of the that's what i'm
looking for that's the achilles heel
however it is still actually useful in
the context that we're going to
work with whenever you use chain rule
you actually can
treat the u of the x very much like a
fraction um the only times when you
can't
are situations we're not really going to
hand you uh things like
this uh if i gave you some function
i'm just going to leave this for a
second there was something like
x squared plus y squared now you're used
to thinking that as a circle
right but only if this left hand part is
a constant of some kind it might not be
what you're getting here is a function
in two
variables now if you were to
differentiate this thing suddenly you
have a bit of a problem that you've
never had to encounter before
which is you have to choose which
variable you're interested in
differentiating with respect to that
sentence is not going to work
so therefore if some of you go ahead and
do uh this level of mathematics at
university
you'll learn there's something called a
partial differential
equation and instead of saying you know
d f
on dx or d y we introduce this other
weird
notation it's just greek right it's like
oh differentiate with respect to y
just treat x to the constant or
differentiate with respect to
x and just treat y as a constant so
in situations like this this is like
cardinal sin number one you can't do
this
so we're in this book with this course
i'm just gonna say go for it
it's totally fine okay but it would be
irresponsible of me to just say
let's just treat it as a fraction it's
more or less like a fraction
it's going to make our question really
easy it's not but under these particular
circumstances
it's okay right that's what you get
because you're an extension of two
students
i'm ready now i don't have any
boundaries to worry about because it's
an indefinite integral
so help me out can we do the
substitution what do i get
i'm going to get this one-third d-u
right because you can see that
substitution happening here so let's go
ahead and put
one-third d-u and then on the
denominator i have
square root of u right now i guess at
this point i can tidy up
a little bit further right that constant
coefficient doesn't really need to be
within the integral and then how would
you suggest i write
that denominator to make it a little
easier to work with
[Music]
[Music]
half so that two that two which you've
actually done
after getting this that two comes from
dividing by the new power
you've got that new power by increasing
this by one
am i done yeah
and then you'll do what's sometimes
called a back substitution right we
introduced you to make things more
convenient
the original question has nothing to do
with you so we'll just restore it back
to what it should be
that's a two-thirds uh i put it the in
index form just to make it easier for
ourselves so i'll go back to radical
form and there's our substitution x q
plus one
happy times okay so as i said
often like even though this is extension
too because you have to choose the
substitution
often actually it sort of writes itself
yeah the substitution isn't too
complicated to choose have a look at
number two
over here on the bottom right hand
corner i'm going to give you a second
time to think about this one again
it's similar to this you're like oh i've
got some square business on a denial
maybe that's going to be problematic
have a think about how you might do the
substitution for this
what choices substitution might be
suitable you might choose one that
actually
leads you down a garden path that's okay
try another one
and then don't forget you also need to
change the variable of integration so
there's an extra step
along with that i'll give you a minute
or two to get a head start of me and
then we'll start working